okay right the state of screenwriting in
2014 is very diffuse it's losing the old
boundaries between screenwriter director
screenwriting and television writing
this year our speakers have reflected
the multidisciplinary approach to
filmmaking so we have James Shamus
producer executive of Focus Features for
many years and a renowned screenwriter
Emma Thompson award-winning actor
screenwriter Steven Knight award-winning
writer and director I think this year
you're going to see three very different
lectures far more diverse than in the
past
most people think of Emma Thompson
primarily as an actor
what they may overlook is the fact that
in 95 she won the Oscar for Best Adapted
Screenplay for Sense and Sensibility
I think Emma's going to bring an insight
into both acting and screenwriting the
actors need and the screenwriters skills
the marriage of those two is what I'm
looking for she does want to perform
quite what she wants to perform I don't
know I think that's part of the joy of
an evening with Emma Thompson you're
never quite sure what's going to happen
so the combination of a performance and
a lecture is going to make this a unique
evening
um without me having to tell you how I
write because that's how I write I've
left my water over there and water this
is I've got a purple yoga mat there are
rarely chips but it's a good idea now
I've come to think of it and I have a
little table about that size and that's
sort of what it looks like and that's
what I do
I never I am I find odd places to to
polish you know places that I haven't
seen in a long time sometimes parts of
my own body
why not yeah I why not I think it's good
to know what the process is like there's
a lot of weeping as well a lot of crying
um I thought I might might as well start
at the beginning since we're talking
about writing yeah and um I think that
it's very interesting where writing
comes from where your relationship with
words comes from and I think mine comes
yes from reading of course but from my
father who wrote the Magic Roundabout
and was a an actor who was said that BBC
gave him these little French films and
said would you write the scripts for
them because we can't put them on in
French and my father who hated the
French openly was very rude in fact to
Serge don't know who created those
puppets so there was never much warmth
between them and he would sit at this
funny little machine which he would work
with his foot and it was a reel-to-reel
and he would sit writing this script as
a little girl I watched a sudha history
watching him just sitting there with his
headphones on with this old machine for
hours and hours and hours on is that I
was gripped with it because that was how
he scripted it he just watched the
pictures and made things up because
which is do you think about it
screenplay writing is same thing only
the other way around but he also taught
me something else about it which I'm
sure relates to the things we're going
to talk about later which was that he
was writing things for children
ostensibly these were and he made no
concession to that whatsoever
he said children are just people who
simply haven't lived as long as we have
so there's no need or reason to talk
down to them as though they are from
another planet so I would I grew up with
that and like alan bennett who grew up
with a father who would chase a dog out
of his butcher shop with the words get
out of here you filthy lamppost smelling
article you understand where it all
comes from and it's interesting anyway I
thought it no answer diverge I like I
really like that the derivation of it
and we will come back to that tell me
you went to university you started
writing when how old we only start
writing um I started writing I always
wrote I wrote stories at school I
started writing sketches I was doing
sketches with footlights yeah when I was
eighteen nineteen and one time the
footlights that is me and amongst other
Stephen Fry and Hugh Laurie were holed
up by a snow in the Birmingham
Exhibition Centre and we had been
performing at the Phillips small
appliances campaign dinner and I was
about to do a song in a huge Tam
O'Shanter this side and a big black Mac
and I was following a stripper who was
doing the Philips lady shake that's why
I had to come on after in a gigantic
tamo Shanter doing what for 14 years at
the castle of ganache I mean I died the
death and we all did and then we were
snowed in and we were stuck there so I
sat and wrote a sketch about a woman
being caught in a traffic jam just
outside Carlton yes it wasn't very funny
at the time actually I tried I did try
but that's when I started writing
sketches because I was very much
influenced by Stephen and Hugh yeah that
law and footlights really so right when
when I started writing anything you
anger a bit like acting really when I
was asked to act I thought was just like
doing a sketch only for longer and
stand-up was a great training just in
how not to die when you're more
frightened than you have ever been and
will ever be
ever ever ever yes we're going to do a
monologue from around that time but just
before we do do you want to just just
give a little bit of context do you know
I think writing always has roots it's
why nothing is wasted ever you know you
hear things on buses or you hear I heard
this sketch Lenny Bruce on how to relax
your colored friends at parties just
keeps going on about watermelon but it
was written in the 60s you know when
racism he was living right in the center
of it and in the jazz world of course
you know and then the sketch I mentioned
by George Mele was about a Hampstead
liberal hostess talking about how
fantastic it was that she had a black
man at her party I know we see thing is
we've kind of got past that now I mean
let's hope but it was the 19th early
1970s and so this was very cutting edge
political writing and because everything
was political in those days we wrote an
awful lot of of political material and
all of the comedy I wrote really was was
political and it was about everything
that I cared about everything I mean I
would lie under a desk like that weeping
because trying to be funny is awful I'll
do this yeah you want you do I'm doing
basically yeah I I might not be able to
remember I've got Sam's if you've got
the script that's good
I've got the yoga mat as well so if I go
and Rodgers to a standing dog and
that'll be just as interesting and so
you're in an art gallery say and so
that's the art gallery there that's the
walls and you are the pictures and
anyway so hello this is nice isn't it
it's warm for once you don't often get
Barbie nights it England
I like that one I like that one nice and
it sort of blue is that a head do you
think or a melon it's awfully expensive
I don't think I'd want anything up on my
wall but I didn't know whether it was a
head or a melon hmm
what's your name who Pitt Min Ah
Vietnamese oh hello I'm Marjory
henley-on-thames
um oh oh are you a new person
oh god I was reeling hello how is the
damage yeah well I can imagine
Oh over I crude once for my husband
Gerald on it thing in the river once I
was terraces you absolutely wanted to
die silly
come on me oh sorry oh sorry min min
just get back that's interesting got a
lovely smile get that love another thank
you sure do you live in London
hmm what you eat Oh baked beans gosh I
haven't had a baked bean for years so
they're awfully good though are they
wasn't like food wise where you are
oh yes oh it's all for getting hungry
isn't it I remember when I had glandular
fever oh I know I know the feeling awful
hmm do you have children
8
gosh that's a handful are they all here
oh you didn't have to leave them behind
oh god how awful I remember when Gerald
and I went to Florence we had to leave
ours with the team on and I just meant
that little faces out the window staring
houses it's got they saw four women
never could come back who are yours with
well government care can be very good
see something of Vietnamese I'm gonna go
say something love is just like Chinese
I don't speak Chinese I know I'm good
day no no no just so level French
Kamal's of are all that sort of me what
do you do painting decorating interiors
you know huh what these you painted
these oh oh oh I I so sorry I'm so I
didn't think of you as a
what's interesting to me about
performing that now is at the time I was
doing that out of a kind of self-hating
middle-class thing and now I'm terribly
interested in Marjorie and also there's
that synthesis of comedy in politics
that you're talking about because it's
very clear in that when you hear it um
I'm going to do something a bit lateral
now because we talked about about this
and I'm going to talk about failure oh
yeah yeah um because yeah well before we
do um we should put it in context with
Thompson I was commissioned to write a
sketch show in the mid eighties 85 86
yeah and did so yeah I'm with a lot of
weeping and gnashing of teeth and it was
I suppose a kind of signal and perhaps
the most important thing I ever did
because it was such a massive failure
and what what is interesting and
important about it is that after that I
didn't write sketch comedy anymore I
never wrote another monologue I never
wrote another sketch and I think that's
quite tragic actually
hmm and it was oh it was a terrible
experience and I tell the story with
great purpose because I think if you
can't fail like that you can't do this
job now and there's an issue of
resilience that there's a kind of trope
isn't there that's to do with the the
combination of screenwriting as a
negotiation with an industrial scale mmm
industry and the resilience which is
probably genetic that's required because
we were talking about that I'll come
back to it because you've asked me to
read a review but I'm not going to do
that yet because I want to celebrate the
series and and I think this is probably
a moment to show the Victorian Mouse
sketch okay do we show
well not Sunday we were in the
conservatory after dinner John with his
newspaper and I darning a sock when
suddenly he laid aside his newspaper and
pointing to something in his lap said do
you know what this is
well I leant over and was somewhat taken
aback to see an organic object the shape
of a cigar nestling up to him but I
leant over to examine it better and
whilst taking out my eyeglass I feel my
eyesight is weak of Allah and remarked
on what an interesting looking little
object it was whereupon on my life Lamar
it shrank into itself like a telescope
before my very eyes I confess I shrieked
aloud
how extraordinary
but gusta do go to your room dear no I
want to hear the story what is a
creature from his laboratory exactly as
I thought my dear perhaps he has brought
him an experiment but there it lay
utterly in that looking for all the
world like like a small pink hairless
Mouse Shh go to your room Augusta
what's the most really dead I feel so
dear girl can I make a shroud for the
man please let us drop the subject
husband I really cannot recall
yes oh yeah so sketch about her Winnie
sex and laughter - really yes yeah I'm
so glad you loved you didn't laugh as a
pity well I don't care I'll take it
um I used to have violent arguments
about the nature of comedy with my peers
at the time and particularly with Ben
Elton who was em you gotta have a joke
you've got over gotta have a punchline
you gotta have a punchline I said I
don't you do have to have a punchline
I think you need to punch them when
you're a boy because men's jokes are
essentially something that goes on and
on leading to it an ejaculation at the
end and women's comedy is more circular
there are little laughs here and then
there's a big laugh and then there's
another little laugh and it's so I think
that are humorous as it were DNA Jenna
goes hand in hand with our sexual yeah
with our orgasmic come nature you know
that men's going to talk about this for
a long time yes I think really has to
have very well Elena Michael I do want
to I want to move it on because I want
to get to Sense and Sensibility okay and
I want to talk about how that came how
that came to you yeah and what you first
did about suddenly being asked to adapt
a classic like that okay um well it came
to me because of that sketch yeah
because they actually showed the that
series in America I think it was on at 3
o'clock in the morning or something on
some obscure Channel you know Iceland
today or something and but my great
friend Lindsey Duran who produced dead
again which is a film I made with Ken
Branagh all those years ago
um and Scott Frank he's one of yours
yeah um she was watching it and she
thought that's the woman I want to adapt
a Jane Austen novel
go figure so she said would you like to
adapt and accessibility and I said what
I think I prefer to adapt persuasion
wouldn't but I mean I've never adapted
anything why would you I don't know how
so she said would you be interested I
said sure I mean I'll have a go I will
I'll have a go I'll what'll I do I'll go
and ask Ruth provigil Varla who's a very
good screenwriter what to do and Ruth
said a dramatized the whole book and
then see which bits work and then take
everything else away and try and make
those bits then you have to write your
bits yes because where do you where do
you begin in it end there's that's
that's the trick of course because
adaptation is is both distillation yeah
and a kind of imaginative invention that
you have to use to create your own
skeleton because you can't put a whole
novel onto the screen it's not possible
No so I sat outside it was a nice summer
and I wrote the first draft and I
adapted the whole thing and it was about
600 pages long yeah quite long no I love
very long quite long books and totally
just being the norm yes yeah yeah and
then I started to kiss a story it's like
I suppose what they'd like piece of
sculpture you know you get that you're
that mound of paper which is in there
somewhere yes I love the fact that
you've bought them I brought this these
are all the drafts of Sense and
Sensibility and this I think is the
first one yeah so this mound of paper is
just the novel more or less it's all
written on the back of old script
everything in there is and and then you
wrote it by hand first yes I write
everything by hand yeah this there's a
few drafts there they're all handwritten
um there's seventeen drafts um what I
like about the box is that most people
don't see that process most people you
know you say to them you've done 17
drafts and they go oh yeah really and
it's all in a floppy disk or your hard
drive yeah that's actually yes five
years yeah and not all the time I mean
and what's interesting is as well that
because
act 2 there's one draft in there that I
wrote while we were shooting much ado
about nothing where everything's very
Tuscan there's a lot of olive oil in the
sunshine something very Eleanor
leaps out of the shower yeah anyway um
Lindsay said you know I do understand
why this is so so sun-soaked but you
have to throw the entire draft away and
go back to the one before and and work
on that yeah and that's what happens
sometimes and you just have to bite your
tongue and go okay all right
and Lindsay was your editor well oh yes
she I call her my editor she's I think
all writers all writers novelists poets
everyone needs a good editor
I think they keep the key thing that the
key point that you're making which is
very very important for people to to
understand is that that unless you're in
a conversation with someone in the
development stage of a screenplay it's
almost impossible to work through to the
point of final draft because it it is a
collaborative medium yeah um
Eleanor the character of a loner hmm
what was that what was the thing about
her that you that drew you to her and
that you wanted to kind of draw out in
the screenplay what was it about the
nature of her emotionally and in the
peace walk that you were looking to kind
of find and bring to the surface well
it's an interesting book Sense and
Sensibility because it's her first as
you know and it's very arcane the
language but harking back to the 1700s
late 1700s rather rather than the early
1800s and so it's it's complex but she's
very very simple I mean she's all about
duty and honor really I mean she is
honor
lisanna fide and what was so interesting
about finding Angley as a director
because he wasn't famous then at all was
that he'd just written eat/drink
man-woman which is all in Chinese and
had one line in it where an older sister
turns around to the
sister and says what do you know of my
heart which is exactly what Eleanor says
to Mary Ann and that we'd both written
the same line in two different countries
separated by what well clearly not very
much and I'm conscious listening to you
that all that you're talking about is
the detail of negotiating with a classic
novel and trying to bring yourself in
your feelings that have been evolving
through the sketch comedy and everything
to that work and what I'm also conscious
of is that when you reach the point
where a film is made your screenplay has
to do many things but one of the things
it has to do is to have a structural
integrity that can withstand
navigating filmmaking there's there's
the script you know you can think of a
film us having a lodestone and then you
put those then you build the bridge
around it and the bridge is the point
you know but the lodestone is there and
if the stone is taken away the Keystone
forgive me of an arch if it's taken away
the arch will fall so without it it's
impossible and it has those angles to it
but there are so most of a great of a
screenplay that holds water like a
balloon that you can you can bash it and
twist it and change it and but it will
always hold its water yeah so some water
might move and that it may change shape
but it will it will not burst and and
what is so interesting and mysterious
about great spring screen places that
you could make the whole thing in a way
I suppose making a film is like adapting
a screenplay
you adapt the whole thing to film and
then you take out the bits that work you
can't use the stuff that doesn't work
you have to cut it and and what's
interesting about that is that you can
shoot something that has been essential
in the screenplay essential and then you
film it you've adapted it to film and
you watch it and you think I've seen
that I can see it so I don't need to
have that scene and yet everybody up to
the point of filming thought it was
going to be nuts so I'm like that's very
keys because you're describing what you
just seen
so this is the interesting thing so it I
suppose adaptation is is is is indeed a
double process
you adapt up to screenplay and then the
screenplay is adapted into a film and it
was Anthony Minghella who said that
editing is the final rewrite this is
actually said which of course is what
you're doing in that moment yeah well
you know what we don't need it those
exactly and then there's another
mysterious thing that can happen which
is by excising something not only from a
screenplay but also from a film this
works on both pieces of work you can
make the doctor position of the two
remaining scenes so much more powerful
by leaving something out I mean I think
screenplays are about ellipses the
ellipses so write everything and then
take out the stuff and take out as much
as you can until you're right the end
just going but it's still there
somewhere but what's left really pings
out because of what you've taken away I
can't explain why that works look but it
sometimes works in performance as well
so it seems to me that art of all kinds
performance art it's all to do with
energy it's all about energy let's talk
about endings because there's another
analogy that Jim Sheridan drew oh yeah
which is to do with energy um which i
think is really profound and really
helpful and obviously uh the end of a
film is what you meant to say but you
you were working with Jim on in the name
of the file yeah okay he said we were
talking about screenplay writing and he
said the ending some some screenwriters
it's the beginning but it's Eva so he
said the ending is should be like a
magnet and that when you start you think
that in your head immediately you get
this pile of iron filings over here
which are the scenes and the characters
and the words which lift are pers and
then as you get closer to the magnet
they get more and more magnetized and
then they start going faster and faster
and faster and faster and if up till the
end and then there
all just forth and that's the feeling
you get when you go to see a really
great film at the end it's all those
iron filings have just gone whoosh and
you go out filled up with this
incredible energy and it is it's not
like the energy of electricity I think
great art and a great film needs to be
that so you're you know that that's your
iron filings and and then the magnets
your ending and the relationship between
those two things that seem to me to be a
very helpful tip incredibly useful very
powerful and I want it before we come on
to Nanny McPhee I just want to talk
about you as an actor and the way that
your your tools as an actor fold into
the experience of writing to what extent
do you bring your actors and 10i to
writing or are the two different
elements of the same journey I think I
bring them all the time I mean you saw
me then you were in the room muttering
to me yourself
yeah so I will tend to act all the roles
I will tend to try not to write
something that I think can't be said
that I can't be spoken I mean I when I'm
learning when you'll learn as an actor
god almighty when you're trying to learn
bad writing forget it you just can't
learn bad writing it's just impossible
but good writing it just goes into your
system it's such a joy to learn good
writing and such a pain it's awful
learning bad right sometimes you have to
you don't we don't always get to do
wonderful things on what we want to do
that's not that's not what this job is
like what life is like but but when it's
good my gosh is you're so grateful talk
about Nanny McPhee now um so how did
that come about how how was that landed
at your door and well that was me
actually it was one of those odd things
when I was hoovering I was hovering in
the room which has got most of the books
in it my
house and I saw this little tiny volume
lifted it out
nurse Matilda by Christiana brand and I
sat down and looked at it and thought I
remember these books about that nanny
who come to Jesus terribly frightening
and ugly but by the end when they've
learnt all their lessons she's very
pretty and there's something about that
I really don't like but there's
something about that that I think is
very interesting and actually quite
anarchic oh I wonder if that would make
a good film this was long for guy was
born yes because I had chosen like my
father I wasn't writing for children I
was writing for myself and I found this
little book and I sent it to Lindsey and
said I think I'd like to write this as a
film and she said brilliant idea and she
doesn't always say that and I thought
good sense accessibility it was so hard
really hard burger or cane writing Jane
Austen you know tubs of iconic novelist
this will be so much easier nine years
later seven years in development the
first script of Nanny McPhee
is not even remotely anything
I think there's anything in the first
group of nanny mcphee that was in the
last group because it was so difficult
to adapt because there's no story yep
and there's something else which is
which you've touched on this Christian
and Branagh novels are more picaresque
more sequential than a structured novel
particularly with Nanny McPhee - was
that you really only had the idea but
the idea is the key isn't it yes well I
was in the Hitler's favorite hotel
though tired lon
he loved it there and and doing the
publicity for the first nanny
yeah and I thought Oh war hmm that would
be good
that's where I got the idea in Berlin
and then I thought ah but I'm gonna have
to write the whole thing there's nothing
there's nothing here so it's a location
in name only really yeah it means taking
a character it's taking that shape which
we're gonna talk about our way because
in fact I worked out some time ago that
Nanny McPhee is a Western yeah
the Western is the the an arc basically
all the cowboy whoever is you know it's
a guy and which we just have to live
with and he comes into a situation where
order has broken down of some kind order
has broken down and he restores order
using unorthodox methods and then must
leave the vital thing is that he must
leave or be killed he cannot stay he
can't become part of that world
what's important is he's the outsider
and it was it was that when I was doing
think the thinking about nanny mcphee I
realized that actually I was placing the
elements that I had learnt as a young
child of the Western and I had
domesticated them and put them into a
nursery where after all we keep our most
precious feelings and our most precious
beings and we're the place that we would
defend with our lives
we're it to come to it so of course it
makes perfect sense that that but it's a
West of it yeah it does and and before I
open up to the floor I just touched on
you as an actor um and we talked a bit
about editing uh I think it's
appropriate to end by talking bit about
a mystery you know the chimerical nature
of of this strange relationship between
screenwriting performing in that
triangle of camera director actor yeah
because it isn't something that you can
just there is no science to it no you
know well that's what's exciting about
it there's a wonderful quote which might
be the good thing to mmm and on where
it's a choreographer actually and she
was called Agnes DeMille and she said
living is a form of not being sure not
knowing what next or how the artists
never entirely knows we guess we may be
wrong but we take leap after leap in the
dark good huh
that's it
let's open it up to the floor I'm a
playwright I've been working as a
playwright for quite a few years and I'm
trying to get my first screenplay made
and do you have any advice first sort of
like the differences in style or
secondly just how do you get a
screenplay made okay um as to getting
something made your guess is as good as
mine it's not that again there is no
science to that either you have to god I
don't know
I mean gem help me out here you also are
a screenwriter I think there isn't a you
know you're absolutely right there isn't
a science and honestly I'm afraid we go
we have to go back to resilience because
you know we can we come back to this
this trajectory of failure because you
know someone would think oh well every
script you've written gets made I mean
we disabuse people of that know I've
written load most of the screenplays
I've written have not been made so it's
very important you know and the ones
that I haven't been made I've worked
very very hard on believed in and loved
and thought they were good but they
haven't been made so or you know I've
handed them in and then somebody years
later has made it with the different
script and said oh yeah we just left you
all so I've often left completely on the
scrapheap
without anyone even telling me so I
don't get very well treated as a writer
either so that's comforting isn't it
this lady here you had your hand up
earlier mmm thank you
my daughter and I were discussing those
who feel entitled and those who feel
unentitled and in doing so found that we
shared the same role model and so we've
collaborated on this role model and come
up with the script just curious who's
your role model oh um well oh I was
hoping you were going to say me I really
had to control what was into my face I
was just ready to go can I ask my
question again so much so glad that I'm
your role model and your daughter's role
model and then I had to do something
completely different with my face thanks
I mean Jeremy said before you must be
honest in these things and I think it's
important to be honest as their their
you my role model is my mother because
she is a great writer she was my first
editor um so uh and she was editing me
obviously long after my father had died
because he would have been a very good
editor and so I was very lucky in that
both my parents could and can write
don't do it
and gentlemen
you
you
you